okay hello everyone welcome to my talk
making of a mosquito
uh here are my details i would love to
talk about myself more
but we only have 10 minutes so we got to
get through it quick
but again if you have ever seen
me on the internet before or or in any
of my talks you'll kind of know that
i really want to get people into
creating things and i think it's the
best way to learn and teach
and grow and all around have fun
so the reason that i wanted to make a
mosquito in the first place was to
explore the web audio api i wanted
something not too crazy
and not too simple to learn the web
audio api can be
a little intimidating it even mentions
that in the mdn documentation
um so i built this beautiful sanity
child to track
my sanity over time i like the chart at
this point because
it shows that sanity could potentially
go above one
when that is truly not the case but with
every project
you kind of just got to start with your
building blocks and for me that is a
small html page
referencing a script and in that script
i just have one single line to begin
let context equal new window.audio
context the audio context is
how you access the web audio api
so if we were to look at my mosquito and
i just have to emphasize how much i
truly despised this emoji
it would just be the audio context now
to get noise from the web audio api you
need a couple more things i need an
oscillator node and a gain node
um and don't worry i'm not going to
allow you here i'm going to go back and
explain these but
the way that i the reason that i want to
do it this way is because this is how i
built it and then i kind of reverse
engineered backward towards making the
mosquito so if i had my code
i would have the context i'd be creating
an oscillator node you can see that it
comes from that context that web audio
context
i'd be creating a gain node and then
i would be connecting my gain node to
the oscillator node
and i'd be connecting the context
destination which is the output the
speakers
to the gain node and then i also have to
add a button in
because back in the day we allowed auto
playing audio and
the world ruined it for everyone
so this would be my mosquito at the
start and this would sound exactly like
this
a very annoying buzz uh kind of space
noise my sanity immediately started to
go down
i immediately had to search how to
reduce web audio api volume
and lo and behold up comes the gain node
so we figured out what that does
um it also mentions in the gain node
never change this value directly but
i never stopped to think if i should and
i decided that i will just change that
value directly
and it reduced the volume to half and
that one that you heard just then was
actually half already it was
really really loud so if we looked at my
mosquito now
it would be an oscillator node a gain
node and an audio context we know what
the gain node is
but what does this oscillator node do
well it turns out that the oscillator
node is responsible for emitting a sound
wave
much like the sine wave that you see
here
and it has a few properties on it it has
a frequency which is the frequency of
the wave and it has a type
there's a bunch of different types of uh
of
waves that it can emit and of course a
mosquito would be the most intimidating
sounding type which is the sawtooth
and then i did a little research into
frequencies of mosquitoes
and there are a lot of videos online
upsettingly and i also kind of learned
that you could just jack the frequency
up to about 10
000 and make that noise that only dogs
and small kids can hear
do with that information what you will
um
so i played around with my oscillator
node the sawtooth again was the best
uh the best node type for this and i
set the frequency to about 750 and that
gave me a mosquito
that sounded a little like this
very annoying i had to reduce the volume
again straight away
sanity is at an all-time low of 0.8
the graph has figured out now that it's
not going to go above that
but this mosquito i would call the base
mosquito it's the yarn create mosquito
the mpm init mosquito the user bin
mosquito
that's where it would live sanity is
falling at a rapid rate at this point
i've been playing with this for 30
minutes or something i listened to
mosquito videos it was all kind of going
crazy in my head i decided that i need
to stop the mosquito noise
you know at the moment i was refreshing
it was really difficult to debug
um and the oscillator had to start and
stop so i thought okay
let me just plug that in to the mosquito
so i can press that button i can press
it again to stop
but at this point i'd already closed all
my tabs multiple times because i
felt that i was still hearing the
buzzing afterwards
i decided to add a clap audio noise to
give me a small
brief moment of satisfaction so
[Music]
there we had our clap and our ending of
the mosquito i decided to add in
some ascii art because i was really
losing the plot
and then i found this when i tried to
start my mosquito again
it turns out you can't restart an
oscillator node once you've called stop
on it i have no idea why
my best guess is that once you clap a
mosquito completely out of existence
you can't obviously clap a mosquito into
existence
so i had to do a bunch of different
things here
i had to start the oscillator node when
i initially clicked the button
and then otherwise i would disconnect or
reconnect the gain node
my sanity again took a big hit here
because
i knew that every time i stopped the
mosquito it was secretly oscillating
behind the scenes
uh waiting for its opportunity to strike
now if we think of the mosquito that i
have at the moment
this again here's the noise
you can hear the pain you can feel the
pain uh the
equivalent of that would really be a
mosquito just kind of sitting hovering
above us
uh at exactly the same spot looking down
and although that would be intimidating
i kind of wanted to
make the mosquito a little bit more
bumbling and frustrating
than the stuck mosquito in the sky and
between that frequency and
uh and type option there was detune i
didn't really need to read what detune
was because at high school
a lot of people played wonderwall on
their guitar and i had great experience
with detune
now my sanity is low at this point it's
below the 0.6 line
that i call the insane or genius line
you know i've set up my
citronella candles on spraying
everywhere i'm in trouble for doing that
okay but i decided to build the mesquite
engine
and the mesquite engine is what i was
going to use to detune the mosquito so
if i were to just set that originally up
on a sine wave
[Music]
you can hear then that it goes up and it
goes down
as as with the sine wave now that
mosquito would just be kind of hovering
up and down which again would be
intimidating but
not completely what i was going for um
so i decided to
rather than completely just keep adding
to the sign counter
putting it round around i decided that
25 of the time
i would move backwards and 50 of the
time i would move forwards
and the other remaining 25 percent it
would just stay static which gives us
this staggered mesquite engine i call
mesquite engine 0.5 and if you were to
listen to it
you can hear that there it is much much
more like a mosquito
um i felt that it needed a little bit
more variance so i
added a small pusher and puller in the
middle of that
this variable will just go up to 0.6 or
down and it would just randomly 50
of the time go up or down that small
little push looks like this
and if i were to attach that uh to the
end
of my already rotating broken rotating
mesquite engine i would have what i call
mesquite engine 1.0
[Music]
now that is a mosquito if i've ever seen
one but now that i've got this mesquite
engine running the detune why don't i
connect it to all the pieces if i
connect it to the gain node i can
control the volume
and it can go up and down again with the
[Music]
mosquito
that is really starting to get onto the
annoyance of a mosquito
and i thought what else do i hate about
mosquitoes aside from everything and one
thing that's really difficult about
mosquitoes is trying to triangulate the
noise when they're in your room or
they're near
you know you're looking up you're trying
to find it you want to get it
and it turns out there was one more
beautiful piece in the web mosquito api
called the stereo panet node
and the stereo panna node which i'm
going to connect to the mesquite engine
of course
controls the left or the right speaker
now i'm not too sure if this will come
over the stream but this was
my absolute complete mosquito
infuriating infuriating infuriating uh
that is my talk thank you everybody
uh presenting this to you of course has
brought my sanity straight back up to
the top
thank you for the time